I am rolling and rolling and rolling  rolling rolling rolling you know I'll do  this all I think I I don't give a [ __ ] I  mean hey what's up a lot of pot please  panic I said elongated already right  what's another word for that longer over  though that volvo volvo and it looked  like there was a lot of layering cuz  there was a lot of layering however her  nerdy saw a lot of ah look so dry then  see ya over there I'll take tons of  shorts so if you've got quads that are  sick as the day is long and just amazing  saatchi yeah laughing a man like you  don't have a show and I love whole lot  of the designer mix these metallic items  with classic menswear pieces genius for  all your fashion needs check out details  calm for some great tips and advice and  be sure to follow me on twitter at  details matt see you next season and see  okay  you